we're not going to fix climate change
climate change is a thing that is we're
going to be living with now in in
perpetual time
there's not going to be a fix for
sea-level rise or a fix for droughts or
anything like that they're going to be
various adaptations various ways of
dealing with it better and worse than
others but we're not going to fix it
it's it's it's our world now and this
notion that you know the land is here
the sea is there and we live in this in
this because the world that we see is
the world we think is always going to be
there and has always been there what
climate change is teaching us is that
the world is in huge flux and we're it's
moving around very quickly and we're
gonna have to live in a rapidly changing
world and so how do we think differently
in order to embrace that is I think one
of the big questions in the center of
all this